HERE ARE SOME OF THE WORST
MOMENTS FROM TONIGHT'S DEBATE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT CANNOT GO ON THIS WAY.
WHEN I AM PRESIDENT, WE WILL
EVEN UP THE SCORE AND WE WILL
TAX THE PLOT OF THE WEALTHY.
SPEAK OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
AND THE DEMOCRATS WATCHING
TONIGHT ARE THE LAST BEST HOPE
FOR HUMANITY ON THIS PLANET.
>> DONALD TRUMP FROM CHARLESTON
TO BALTIMORE, TO EVEN THE
BORDER, IS USING THE TIRED OLD
LANGUAGE OF DEMAGOGUES, OF
FEARMONGERS, OF RACISTS.
STEAM DOME ASKED LET'S START
OF COURSE, BEING LESS THAN
CANDID, LACK OF CANDOR.
BUT WE CAN'T HAVE A TWO-TIER
JUSTICE SYSTEM EITHER.
I THINK WE REALLY HAVE TO.
>> IT STUNNING.
>> I ACCEPT HIS JUDGMENT.
I'VE KNOWN HIM FOR 20 YEARS.
I HAVE NO DESIRE FOR HIM TO BE
LIKE MUELLER.
I WANT HIM TO DO WHAT HE THINKS
IS RIGHT BY THE LAW AND NOT
PROSECUTE ANYBODY.
THERE'S NO REASON TO CONTINUE
THAT PRACTICE.
IF IT'S TRUE, AND WE WILL KNOW
PRETTY SOON, IT'S STUNNING,
BEYOND STUNNING.
>> Sean: HERE'S MY
INTERPRETATION.
WHAT DO I KNOW?
I DON'T KNOW A LOT OF ANYTHING.
I KIND OF SEE BARR AS A REALLY
THOROUGH, EXTRAORDINARILY BRIGHT
HUMAN BEING.
THEN I'D SAY THAT PROBABLY BARR
HAS RECOGNIZED THE FISA ABUSE
ISSUE.
IF HE WAS WARNED THAT ITS
UNVERIFIABLE.
HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
WE NOW KNOW, ACCORDING TO THE
MEMO, THE BULK OF THAT
INFORMATION WAS IN FACT, THE
DOSSIER, THE     THE KNOW YOUR T
DOSSIER, THE     THE KNOW YOUR M
DOSSIER, THE     THE KNOW YOUR E
DOSSIER, THE     THE KNOW YOUR S
DOSSIER, THE     THE KNOW YOUR Y
DOSSIER, THE     THE KNOW YOUR .
THE RUSSIANS WERE FAVORING
HILLARY.
HE'S NOT PLAYING CHECKERS.
HE SEES THAT THERE ARE BIGGER
FISH TO FLY DOWN THE ROAD.
BUT WHAT DO I KNOW?
>> I THINK YOU KNOW A LOT ABOUT
THIS.
IF BILL BARR SAID, THERE MAY BE
A CASE THERE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT FOR NOW.
THE POINT IS, IF YOU'VE GOT SOME
DOUBT ABOUT THE VALIDITY OF THE
CASE, JUST DON'T THROW IT UP
AGAINST THE WALL.
>> Sean: WOULD YOU WANT THE
FIRST CASE YOU BROUGHT IN
JEOPARDY OF NOT WINNING?
>> YOU KNOW A LOT ABOUT
PROSECUTION.
THE WORST THING YOU COULD DO IS
OVERCHARGE SOMEBODY.
IT TAINTS THE THING THAT REALLY
IS SO STRONG.
>> Sean: YOU ARE THE LAWYER.
I'M LEARNING FROM YOU.
>> I USED TO DO THIS FOR A
LIVING.
THERE'S TWO WAYS TO DO THIS.
THROW EVERYTHING INCLUDING THE
KITCHEN SINK AT THE ACCUSED.
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN YOU CHARGE
HIM, YOU WILL NOT BE UNDERMINED
BEFORE BECAUSE YOU OVERCHARGED.
THEY TRIED TO SCARE PEOPLE.
THE FACT THAT BARR IS SHOWING
SOME PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION,
IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
IF HE DOES BRING A CHARGE
AGAINST COMEY, I'D HATE TO BE
COMEY.
>> Sean: I THINK I'D HATE TO
BE COMEY.
HE HAS THE RIGHT TO REMAIN
SILENT.
I ADVISED HIM TO TAKE THAT RIGHT
SERIOUSLY.
I'M JUST GOING TO ADVISE HIM,
NOT ONLY DO YOU HAVE THE RIGHT,
IF I WAS YOU, SUPER PATRIOT, I
WOULD JUST SHUT UP, BECAUSE YOU
ARE HURTING YOURSELF EVERY TIME
YOU OPEN YOUR BIG MOUTH.
I CAN'T BE ANY MORE BLUNT THAN
THAT, BECAUSE I'M A TALK SHOW
HOST.
>> THAT ONLY HURTS YOU DOWN THE
ROAD.
SO IF THERE WAS AN ABUSE OF THE
PFIZER PROCESS, IF THERE WAS A
MISLEADING OF THE COURT, BY THE
FBI DIRECTOR, THAT IS A
MONUMENTAL CRIME, AND I WOULD